- You have two boys.
Do they help in the kitchen now?
- Yes, four and two.
Hugo and Gus and-
- Taste test.
- They tell me what to cook.
They try to help and
I'm their private chef.
And no matter what I make,
they almost never eat.
So it's a problem for me.
- That actually makes me feel good.
'cause when I do cook, I'm like,
"Do you know how hard this was for me?"
I don't do this and I
feel like I did a good job
and they do not eat it.
And I'm like, it makes me feel good
that you're an actual chef.
And yeah, they just are like,
"Hard pass, where's the mac and cheese."
- Yeah, they want mac and cheese.
They want all shades of brown foods.
- Beige! My son eats nothing
but beige.
- Beige anything.
- Mine even, it's gotten to the point
where I definitely take orders,
but I have to actually just,
at this point with Miles,
I said the other day, "He
doesn't eat vegetables."
And I mean, not a carrot stick.
It's just like a big-
- My son will not.
He's like, "Absolutely not."
- Thank you.
- "Hard Pass."
- No one wants to admit to that.
But then, I was like, oh
no, it goes past that.
I can offer him a root beer float.
He doesn't wanna try
that. He doesn't wanna...
I'm like, "Please try this Coca-Cola."
And then I'm like, "Why am I trying?"
It's just be being crazy.
- But my son is the same though.
I have to sneak it in,
into a cup that's colorful,
that you can't tell what the color is.
And that's how I sneak it in,
is like a juice or a smoothie.
He will not do it, and he'll smell it out,
and be like, "This is a vegetable."
And he is hard against it, yeah.
- Same.
- I mean, it's like,
I could make him sit there or whatever,
but it just doesn't work.
He'll sit me out.
- I know.
- He will be like, "I'll be
at this table all night long."
- Before kids, you're like,
"If they don't eat what I make,
then they're going to bed hungry."
I'm like, "Oh, what would you like, sir?"
(audience laughs)
- No, I will say if my son were here...
I have sent him to bed hungry.
(all laugh)
Because usually I'm tired.
- Yes.
- I'm like, "I just did this.
If you didn't like it, that's yo problem."
(Chrissy laughs)
- I said, "I made exactly what
you said," and then whatever.